foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar power up
your LNP and aav Sample prep with unagi
I'm Christy Joel of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Unchained labs to learn more about
our sponsor please visit
unchainedlabs.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
I would now like to welcome our speaker
Dr Del Ray jackson marketing manager
buffer exchange and workflows for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
welcome Del Rey you may now begin your
presentation
thanks for that great start Christy
really appreciate that yes I'm here to
talk to you about how you can power up
your LNP and aav Sample prep with unagi
so as a kid growing up reading comic
books and to be quite honest as an adult
who still reads comic books I was super
excited to see this storyline brought to
life in the movies it's okay if you
don't recognize this character but he's
one of my favorite and what you know
really drew me to him as a kid is that
he goes on this quest to collect these
different stones to gain ultimate power
and what I thought was so cool is that
each of those gems that you see there in
his Gauntlet gave him a different Power
like one gave him power power over time
another over space and another over
reality and he while he does do some
pretty amazing stuff unfortunately as
probably most of you know he is a
villain so he is ultimately brought down
by the heroes
but speaking of amazing stuff many of
you are already doing that every day as
you do buffer exchange for these
essential biomolecules for gene therapy
so whether you're working with lipid
nanoparticles the quest that you have to
go on is to gently and quickly remove
the organic solvent after production to
keep lnps from growing in size if you're
working with viral vectors then what you
need to conquer is concentrating what is
often a very dilute aav or viral
production and at the same time also
needing to buffer exchange them and if
you're using everybody's tried and true
favorite nucleic acids the trick with
them is to get them desalted so buffer
exchange them before you can do
Downstream analysis and you want to do
that while minimizing loss and I would
say that goes for probably all of these
biomolecules
and like the heroes Who start out in
their stories maybe not having all the
tools at their disposal using less than
perfect means to achieve what they can
do you might be doing the same with
manual methods for buffer exchange and
concentration so dialysis which can be
very slow and run the risk of sample
dilution might be something that you're
you're stuck to or perhaps you're using
spin columns and centrifuging them down
and having to be tied to the centrifuge
so that you can process you know your
your samples it can be quicker but then
it can have that really annoying
drawback of reducing your sample
recovery due to the membrane clogging
with sample buildup at the interface
and if you use tff it can often be
complicated to set up and really it's
not justified unless you have a large
sample volume
so what's the alternative for this what
can help you power up and Conquer that
would be our unagi which lets you do up
to eight buffer exchanges and or sample
concentrations in parallel that's up to
eight different samples you have a nice
working volume range from a half a mil
all the way up to 48 mils of sample and
you're going to feel like The Flash and
that you can set all of this up really
in just a few minutes definitely less
than 15 minutes of Hands-On time for all
of your runs
so how does this work well let's get
started with the consumable it all
starts here with our una this is where
your samples go in and you see a single
one on the left there that is the vessel
that has a eight mil volume range and
the working volume range is down to half
a mil you can see how we can process up
to eight of those as they go in that
sample rack pictured on the right and
something I really like about the sample
rack and I hear the same from customers
is that they can take that to their
bench they can take time to prep the
unas which you just pre-wet them with di
water
or a buffer uh let them sit for a few
minutes and then you can pipette your
sample right into them you can lock them
right into place in the sample tray and
then take it over to anagi at your
leisure
the membrane options that you have with
unagi are 10 30 and 100 kilodalton and
good news they are made out of
regenerated cellulose why is that good
news that's because it doesn't have
specific Affinity or strong binding for
many of these biomolecules that you see
okay so now you have your samples in
your Uno what happens next well this is
where the real power of unaki comes in
we refer to the technology the buffer
exchange technology on unagi as an
automated pressure-based ufdf UF
standing for ultra filtration which just
refers to the size of the biomolecules
that we're filtering out diet filtration
is when you add new buffer back in as
you filter from it and I really like
this cartoon
comic because it shows at a glance some
of the cool powers of this technology so
after inputting your samples the first
thing that unagi does is it measures
each sample's volume uh it uses an
ultrasonic tool which we'll see in a
moment exactly and then it continues to
track that volume by taking more volume
measurements in every cycle here so in
the middle of the screen the screen
Arrow refers to the Cycles the buffer
exchange or concentration cycles that
are required and we apply an even
positive pressure and we do this at 15
30 and 60 PSI and what I mean by even is
that all of your samples are in the same
buffer exchange chamber which we'll also
see in a moment but for exchange chamber
close
pressurizes up to the set pressure level
and then allows that filtrate to flow
out now the cool part is that you don't
have to come back and figure out you
know which samples maybe float faster or
slower or exactly how much new buffer to
add back you're not doggy does all of
that because it will re-measure the
volume at the end of each buffer
exchange cycle and the Adaptive part the
cool part is that it will change the
amount of time that we apply that
pressure to make sure that none of your
samples will dry out
goes through a few rounds of buffer
exchange once you have your exchange
sample exchange samples at the end then
we have that option to concentrate
now you might be saying well Dell I work
with AVS or even lmps you know I'm
making 20 50 mils of these things at a
time well that's great we have you
covered with our reduced sample volume
application so the UNA does have an
eight mil working volume limit but by
taking advantage of conical tubes on
your deck you can actually concentrate
from a starting volume of 48 mils all
the way down to half a mil and we'll see
some data of this in action with aavs
towards the end of the talk
the other cool part of unagi a second
gem if you will is the gentle orbital
mixing this is optional so it's
something you can turn on and off you
have the power so to speak to do that
but mostly we see that for many many of
the bio molecules uh as mentioned in the
gene therapy space uh tolerate this
gentle orbital mixing quite well and why
do you want to use that what what's the
benefit well as mentioned before if
you're using a spin filter something
that you notice is that you can lose
sample to that membrane interface due to
something called Dead End ultra
filtration so as you apply a force in
this case centrifugal force across your
your sample it will push not just the
things you want to get out but also the
things you want to keep on that membrane
interface and there you can have things
like nucleic acids your proteins will
will Clump up and aggregate can you know
slow down your buffer exchange unagi
doesn't have that with this gentle
orbital mixing that can occur during the
entire buffer exchange cycle we keep
your molecules of interest in solution
as we as the positive pressure pushes
out the filtrate so it gives you two
things faster results but also better
recovery
we're talking about powering up how you
want to do it so unagi enables that for
you some of the things that you can
control is the percent removal per cycle
why does that matter well there might be
concentration dependencies to your
molecules meaning that if you reach some
sort of critical concentration perhaps
things will fall out of solution or
maybe you just don't want to do that so
you can take just a little bit out a
little bit of the filtrate out per cycle
or if you know that things flow well you
can take a bunch out you have complete
control over that of course that percent
exchange value maybe you need a 99.9
exchange maybe you just need a 94
exchange that's something that you
actually tell lunagi what you want and
using the volume sensor it'll reach that
exact value for your samples
same with the final concentration values
but if you're thinking well Dell I don't
I don't know how to program all this
stuff no worries we have you covered we
have a nice menu option as you can see
here it's based upon the molecule and
the experiment that you want to run so
between aavs nucleic acids lmps and also
works great for proteins we're not going
to see much data on that today but even
the sample dependency of your
biomolecules we have I would say like a
starter set for you but you can also
easily optimize it for you and really it
just changes things like pressure and
Target removal
mostly
and if you're familiar with Unchained
Labs products like our stunner lunatic
or Uncle then you already know that as
many people say we live up to the claim
that our software is easy to use so as
you can hopefully see from these
screenshots here you don't have to
become a super programmer or anything
like that to use unagi really it's a
menu-based system you say which
experiment you want to run if you just
want to do a concentrate only you select
your molecule type and then from there
it's just a few more selections and
you're on your way to running your
buffer exchange and concentration
experiments
something else that's really cool is
that you'll know exactly where unagi is
in the process and it does this in two
ways through the software it'll give you
an overall experiment I would say like
status so you know like which buffer
exchange cycle you're in how long it's
been running what's the expected
completion time but also you get a
sample by sample breakdown really cool
here and if you can notice on your
screen that orange button in the upper
right to the left of the red one is
pause experiment there's some extra
Powers behind that the power to actually
pause the experiment and take out
samples that may have already completed
you know maybe you have different
formulations or slightly different
concentrations for whatever reason some
of your samples May finish before the
others you can pause take those out and
then resume the Run usually that'll give
you uh even a faster run towards the end
and the other cool thing is that um
like I guess some superheroes unagi has
tele telepathy where it can actually
send you a message to your mobile device
at least about where in the run it's at
if it started if it's in and in cases
where maybe it needs like new tips it'll
also alert you for that as well
it is 2022 so even something like buffer
exchange there's no reason why you can't
have accurate logs and reports for it so
if you really want to look like a
superhero to that Downstream analytical
uh or pre-pre-development team that you
might be prepping samples for man you're
going to knock their socks off when you
give them a sample by sample report
showing like initial concentration
volumes and then final concentrations
and exchange rates as as measured by
unagi
okay I keep saying you're Nagi you saw
this picture of a white box but what
what's inside well let's peel off the
mask so to speak and take a look at the
alter ego who who's under the unagi
shell and this is what you see inside so
working from left to right we start with
our buffer rack and just like that Unis
sample rack where you can take it to
your bench and kind of work with your
samples there the buffer rack has the
same functionality so maybe you have a
bunch of different buffers you got to
prepare you know the several conical
tubes with buffer or sample if you're
running that reduce sample volume
application uh the buffer rack is
something you can pick up easily with
the handles and take to your bench or if
you just need to drop a few conical
tubes in there you can leave it there
and bring them over to the instrument
the buffer exchange chamber where all of
this magic happens is located there in
the front and there you can see that una
sample rack locks into place
and then under that beautiful Unchained
Labs logo in the upper right that's the
arm of the unagi there's two different
tools on there number four is the
pipette Channel this allows transfers of
up to one mil of buffer and in the case
of reduced sample volume application
sample because remember we'll take
sample from a conical two and add it to
the UNA
that ultrasonic volume sensor which
almost start with that one right so cool
uh number five you don't see it now it's
a little shy but we'll see a video of it
in a moment I promise you it's there and
then the Disposable tip racks um does
doesn't usually take a bunch of tips and
the other nice thing is you know I can
actually tracks tips between runs and so
you can really just let it go you know
until you run out of tips you don't have
to refill it in between runs at all
and something that's hiding in the
shadows a little bit camouflaged off to
the right the unsung heroes the Caps
these are used in case you want to run
less than eight samples at a time you
could technically run just one sample in
nunagi if you'd like to all you need to
do is put the caps in any of the open
positions and they snap quite easily
into place
all right let's see it in action enough
of me talking so here is that volume
measurement again that occurs at the
beginning of the run and then in every
single buffer exchange cycle uses an
ultrasonic sensor technology so really
just sending acoustic waves you can't
hear them so don't worry
um and it will measure not just the
sample but you also see it make sure
that each Oona is positioned exactly
where it should be so that we can get oh
sorry about that so that we can get
these on the nose measurements so you
can see across our working volume range
we have very good repeatability very
accurate measurements when compared to
gravimetric
and the thing that frees you up so you
can go off and do other work while
buffer exchange is happening obviously
is the buffer editions and so that is
done automatically by unaki uh using air
displaced pipetting technology and how
well does that work well let's see the
results
bang on dispense so we have CVS less
than one percent and this graph on the
right is one of my favorite ones to show
I really get excited for automated
liquid handling you can see over a range
going from water up to 60 percent
glycerol a wide range of viscosities
that we have very accurate um pipetting
across the volume ranges for unagi those
all of these data points are actually
laying on top of each other that's how
accurate and repeatable they are
and then finally we can't forget that we
have the mixing that occurs in the
buffer exchange chamber it's a little
shy so it happens behind closed doors
can actually have between 700 actually
all the way up to a thousand RPM if you
want our recommendation is typically 700
for most sample types
so you put all these gems all these
Powers together and what do you get you
get very nice recovery so this is with
the example of protein we'll look at
some LNP aav nucleic acid specific data
in a moment but you can see that across
whether you're running buffer exchange
buffer exchange with concentrate or that
reduced sample volume application we
have very nice recoveries
it's not just for protein obviously
that's probably why you tuned in was to
see how it would work with these other
biomolecules so here's a quick offering
for you but now what I'd like to do is
take a moment and pretend like we're
going through a workflow like maybe it's
your group alone or you're working in
conjunction with other groups and you're
developing uh drug or doing drug
Discovery and usually the the first step
is examining you know that nucleic acid
payload that you might be having to make
and so again one of the reasons for
doing this is so that you can desalt it
so that you can cue see it Downstream
and in this example we're working with
double-stranded DNA starting in Te and
we want to exchange it into nuclease
free water and taking advantage of unagi
of being able to concentrate in
conjunction we want to shoot for a
three-fold concentration using our 30
kilodalton Una
and the results speak for themselves so
greater than 96 exchange was achieved we
were able to concentrate that three-fold
factor in one uh and we had high
recovery with this
but if maybe your arch nemesis or if
lmps at least getting them
um out of that uh ethanol that organic
phase very quickly after manufacturing
uh unagi is the right tool for you it's
in your corner for sure so you can
automate your LNP prep in one step
here's an example of using sm-102 lmps
starting in 12 ethanol we wanted to
concentrate them four-fold and we're
able to take advantage of our 100
kilodon una to do that
here we had results very fast in less
than two hours but more importantly we
didn't do it at the loss of sample
Integrity so looking at both size and
the distribution measured by PDI you can
see that there was low to no change in
that and which was great and also on top
of it we had minimal percent
encapsulation loss but while doing
buffer exchange and concentration all in
one run
so lmp's come up a lot uh they're used
in our buffer exchange technology and so
we've you know looked at it very
carefully one of the things that we did
was comparing dialysis to centrifuge and
why dialysis well that's a kind of a
go-to a standard technique many people
who make lmps utilize but the drawback
is that it does take take extra time but
you can see why they defer to it because
compared to something like a spin filter
dialysis is much gentler in terms of not
causing size changes or distribution
so compared to a Nagi you can see you
get that same level of care and comfort
um from dialysis with dunagi so here is
the comparison of both dialysis pre and
post buffer exchange with unagi's
results uh really the difference is is
how long it takes so if you want to have
results in the same day then you not use
the tool for you
okay perhaps nanoparticles aren't your
jam that's not your vector of choice
maybe you work with aavs and so in that
case perhaps you're making very dilute
samples on getting them ready and you
need to concentrate them down so here's
an example of how you can use unagi to
do that with first the reduced sample
volume experiment and then concentrate
only we wanted to take aav9 from 12 mils
down to one mil
and we were able to do that so we got
that 12-fold concentration in only 90
minutes while keeping the capsid payload
intact
so obviously you know we're showing you
results for like one stereotype but
there's many different stereotypes that
can behaved differently with aavs and so
in also looking at the effects of pH on
that we've we're looking in the
literature and saw some research on that
so we wanted to in-house using munagi
sort of recreate those results and so in
this case we're looking at a85 and a89
using our 30 kilod molecular weight cut
off una and we wanted to do a buffer
exchange and a concentration and here we
are able to take advantage of the power
of unadi of being able to only take 33
of the volume out per cycle
and so interestingly which agreed with
the literature at a higher
acidic levels or lower pH so ph4 both
aad9 and a85 tended to aggregate so we
didn't have really good recovery with
that but as we increased the pH we could
see that we had much better recovery and
able to get a 96 Target exchange and
very fast run times on these that's one
of the nice things about aads being
dilute they can run very quickly and
here's a nice picture or Comic version
of that
so hopefully I gave you enough of a
teaser to see how unagi can work for you
in your lab you'll be able to do your
buffer exchanges and concentrations and
whether you're working with nucleic
acids or lmps or aavs you can do all of
that work in parallel and it's really a
snap with Nagi having fast and flexible
exchange you'll have full process
control with low Hands-On time but don't
worry about giving up samples sample uh
sacrificing excuse me sample Integrity
or recovery
umagi will take care of you there
so hopefully unlike the previous
character with this great power you'll
use unagi for good in your own lab
and with that I will hand it back to
Christy
thank you Dell for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of our webinar as you
mentioned if you have a question to our
audience well to our audience if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we will answer as many
of your questions as we have time for
so let's get started don't we have quite
a few questions that have already come
in um so I'm just going to start here
what range of sample concentrations can
I run
Ah that's a good question
um you can so typically I answer this
from the perspective of proteins but
we've had good results Christy with
running uh protein samples up to about
200 makes per ml you know and if you've
worked with protein you know that that's
extremely viscous thankfully we don't
really have that problem with lmps or
viral vectors and so pretty much any
concentration working concentration that
we've come across is very compatible
with unagi and then similarly with
nucleic acids and I guess one
clarification I should make is another
related question I get is like well can
you run different concentrations at once
the answer is yes if you remember I had
said that umagi's volume measurement
will always make sure that you you won't
lose sample but if you have a wide range
like magnitude several magnitudes change
in viscosity between sample types as a
function of concentration your your runs
are going to take pretty long so we
recommend like diluting to like you know
categories if you will of concentration
ranges
excellent and thanks for adding that
question in well I won't ask you that
one now
um let's go to this next one how can I
minimize aggregation of aavs during
buffer exchange oh yeah that's a common
problem I didn't touch on it too much
but yes certain stereotypes of aavs and
I don't want to paint any of them as a
villain but between unites the ab2s can
be very prone to aggregation and if
you're already working with them in your
lab you're probably addressing the
buffer conditions as that one study that
I mentioned alluded to you know
different pH ranges will affect
aggregation of aavs you're probably
already using fluoronic acid as well so
you'll want to keep using whatever
buffer conditions you do but the power
of unagi at least like what extra help
does it give you really boils down to
that gentle orbital mixing so we see
that that does keep things in solution
and can minimize uh aggregation of aavs
thanks Dell let's jump into this next
one which LNP formulations have you
tested
uh well I'm a comic book pro and buffer
exchange Pro not an LNP formulation Pro
but in talking with many customers uh
and in you know working internally with
different lnps I would say as you saw
sm-102 which is a very popular
formulation is something that we've
internally tested uh and then we've also
done work with cationic lnps
unfortunately with
um customer supplied lmps it's usually
proprietary information so we don't know
the exact formulations that customers
have so I can't tell you specifically
but we have tested I would say a wide
range
thanks Dill now this question has come
in multiple times so can you elaborate
on how your Tech compares to tff
sure so tangential flow filtration it is
a you know viable technology a viable
alternative and it does have a fit you
know but it's usually more so towards I
would say pre-manufacturing level and so
I would say that unagi does very well
when you're still doing like you know
drug drug screening when you might be
doing some formulation work when you
really just want to have like Fast
results you don't want to have to like
set up up tff also the membrane type so
tff typically only has PES as a membrane
option because of the high forces that
are generated whereas with unagi you do
have the option of regenerated cellulose
thanks Dell and let's go with this
question how long do runs typically take
there can it's it's hard to answer and
I'll probably stumble over the answer we
get asked that a lot that's why I try to
report the the runtimes that you see
here so they do vary but they vary as
they function largely of your sample
viscosity as a function of concentration
temperature you know just your
formulation but I would say most
customers you know AVS and lmps seem to
run very quickly in about that two hour
mark and then nucleic acids maybe just a
little bit longer a couple hours but I
would say even really concentrated uh
proteins are going to be less you know
less than a day for sure to get the runs
done
great and let's see here's another
question that we have
how is the particle size of lnps
impacted by your Technique
that's a good question we've uh We've
looked at that a lot because LMP size
changes are really detrimental right so
you know it affects like the efficacy
for the drug delivery and its uptake and
so in working with customers we really
have a good understanding of how
critical it is to minimize LNP size
changes I would love to say that there's
like zero size change we do see that
sometimes but if you're asking how like
that gentle orbital mixing affects the
size and we've done several internal
studies we see that there's no effect on
the size change really it seems to come
down to the to the amount of time lmps
stay in ethanol that allows them to you
know reform and then deform you know
break apart and then reform I guess into
larger size particles so our technology
the positive pressure the gentle orbit
of mixing those alone do not affect LNP
sizing it's really just how long they're
in that ethanol concentration
thank you Dell and you've given us so
much information today do you have any
final comments for our audience
I guess just thank them and then thank
you Christy and labroot for hosting us
it's been enjoyable I know that you know
might be a lot of follow-up questions
that might come up or perhaps you're
watching watching this on demand our
website uh unchainedlabs.com has a very
nice resource Library you can go there
and you know select by product or you
know application that you want to look
at we have a host of app Notes and other
videos on there to help you and then of
course if you have any questions don't
hesitate you can reach us at support
unchainedlabs.com 24 7 around the world
thank you so much Dr Gallery Jackson we
want to definitely thank you for your
time today and for your important
research and we also want to thank
labroads and our sponsor Unchained labs
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I want to thank our
audience too for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
the questions that we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period they will be addressed
by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration today's webcast can be
viewed on demand and labyrinths will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
thanks for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon have a great day